-Our first guest tonight
is an Academy Award-,
Emmy- and Tony-nominated actor
you know from films
such as "Marriage Story,"
"House of Gucci"
and the "Star Wars" franchise.
He can be seen next
in "Ferrari,"
which will be in theaters
on Christmas Day.
Please welcome back
to the show
our very good friend,
Adam Driver.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
-I -- You know,
I was first introduced
to you on the show "Girls,"
and you were so funny
in that show.
And now you're in
so many wonderful dramas.
It is such a joy for me
to see you become
one of our most accomplished
recent "SNL" hosts.
It is just a joy.
-Thank you very m-- [ Laughs ]
-I feel like we get to see
that side of you.
And you -- you just hosted
for the fourth time.
Have you learned things
between each time?
Do you feel more comfortable?
-Yeah, I feel more comfortable.
You got to learn
when to freak out.
Which the first two days,
you know, it's kind of a wash.
You know, they're very ritual,
and, you know.
But then -- then by Wednesday
you know to kind of get nervous.
-Yeah. That's good.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-You do want to save
your sort of reserves of nerves.
If you waste them
the first two days,
then you, like, have a very
unearned Zen state on Saturday,
which is bad.
-But it does
just kind of go whether or not
you try to stop it or not.
It's going to happen...
-Yeah.
-...and you can't control it,
so you just kind of have to roll
with it, yeah.
-You -- I know from having
worked there,
nothing is better
than when a host comes
and shares one extra skill.
I loved your monologue this time
when you played the piano.
-Thank you. Thanks.
-And, uh, were they --
were they -- I would imagine
they were very receptive
and happy
when you said you wanted
to do that for the monologue.
-Uh, yeah. Yeah, they --
they liked the idea.
The two writers
that they hooked --
I can't remember
their names now,
but they were great.
And, uh...
-By the way, I saw them.
-Terrible.
-I saw them just
before the show,
and I said you were on,
and they said they didn't
remember you either.
-[ Laughs ] Right.
But I remember Wally.
-Yeah. Oh, everybody
remembers Wally, huh?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Um, it was really great.
The movie as well,
"Ferrari" is wonderful.
And the last time you were here,
we were talking about --
I think you were maybe
just about to shoot
or just finished --
the great Michael Mann...
-Yeah.
-...is the director.
Did you have a favorite
Michael Mann film
before you started working
on this?
-Oh. Uh...
hard to -- Hard to say.
Uh, "Heat" and "The Insider"
are probably my two favorites.
And it kind of varies,
you know, month to month --
"Insider," "Heat."
But probably "Heat" has been
the most influential.
-Is he someone who likes
to talk about his old movies
when he's working
when you have downtime?
-He doesn't have
a problem with it.
He has a --
He's very researched,
so he has a lot of details
that that he's -- he's --
But mostly on set,
it's hard to pull him away
from what he's doing.
He's very, you know,
myopically focused.
-That's -- I mean, I guess
you kind of want your director
to be focused and, like, less,
"You want to hear
old showbiz stories."
-[ Laughs ] Right.
-This -- Obviously there's
a great deal of driving
in this film, being that
it's the Ferrari film,
but is it true
that you've been in a car
with Michael Mann
while he's been driving?
-Oh, actually, that is true.
Yeah.
No one's asked me about that.
That was the most scar--
He has a Ferrari.
-Okay.
-And I've driven his Ferrari,
and that's the most scared
I've ever been.
-Just sitting in
the passenger seat?
-Sitting in the passenger seat.
We drove to dinner, and he's
like, "Do you want to drive?"
I'm like, "Yeah, I'll drive."
And then this is a mistake,
'cause he'll try
to direct you how --
driving in California,
the roads are very, um,
they're like this.
So you don't want to scrape
the front part of --
-Oh, yeah, 'cause it's like --
So I wouldn't --
I mean, by the way,
I don't think I'm a good driver,
but if someone was like,
"you want to drive my Ferrari,"
I'd be like, "This is terrible.
No."
-Yeah, yeah.
Especially with Michael.
He's very, you know --
He's paying attention
to everything you're doing.
-Is he the kind of person
that, like --
Is he a talker in the car?
-No, no, he's just focused on
how you're driving his car...
badly.
-That sounds like a disaster.
-It was not a good idea.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. It was awful.
And we had raced up
until that point.
Like, cars going fast.
-Yeah.
-These Radicals
and these Mazda Miatas,
which are very --
already a tight for me...
-Yeah.
-...to be in.
Even the Mazda Miata, my foot
went numb at a certain point
because it's so small.
So I couldn't feel the shift,
you know?
So I'm like,
"I got to get off the track."
But that didn't bother me as
much as riding in a passenger --
riding with Michael in the
passenger seat of his Ferrari.
-I wonder,
like, at the Miata dealership,
when someone as tall
as you walks in,
if they're like,
"Uh, should we tell him?"
-[ Laughs ] Yeah. "No."
-Like, "This isn't for you."
Like, "Don't take it personally,
but you should go elsewhere."
-Yeah.
-Um, so in the film,
you play Enzo Ferrari,
and so you do not --
I know there are a few scenes
where we see you
as a younger Enzo
behind the wheel of a car,
but you didn't actually do
any driving in the film.
-No. No, no, no, no. No.
That's the end of that answer.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Was there a reason?
Was it just that it took place
in a time in Enzo's life
where he wasn't doing
much driving?
-Yeah, well, yeah,
because he wasn't racing it,
and the little,
uh, thing that we did race,
it was like
a very historic vehicle
so they don't want you
driving that around.
-[ Chuckles ] Right.
-And also just insurance reasons
they don't want you driving
around these like --
these kind of replica 801s
that are very dangerous.
We raced those cars
in California,
the ones I was talking about,
and then we raced some
contemporary Ferraris in Modena
and it becomes painfully --
And then I drove a chassis
of one of the cars
that they built
that was a model of the cars
that we used in the vehicle,
and it becomes obvious right
away how dangerous they are.
There's no roll cages,
there's no seat belts.
You know, the goal was to be
thrown from the car
as opposed to get stuck
in the car
and burned to death, so...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, so if you got thrown
from a car, it was working.
-It was a win, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
-As you're going
through the air...
-"This feels right."
-..."this feels perfect."
-Yeah, yeah. [ Chuckles ]
-"I never thought this would
work, and here it is!"
I have a lot more questions
to ask about "Ferrari."
We'll be right back
with more Adam.